le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
partout dans le monde dans beaucoup de
foyers la peur fait partie du quotidien
cette peur est dans la majorité des cas
exercée par un mari ou un conjoint sur
sa femme et ses enfants
la réunion n'échappe malheureusement pas
à cette violence intrafamiliale des
femmes des enfants et parfois des hommes
sont victimes de ces violences sous leur
propres toits
alors pouvons-nous anticipé et stopper
ce type de violences au sein des foyers
on en parle maintenant d'un lien social
c'est à saint denis au théâtre
départemental de champ fleuri que
quelques centaines de personnes se sont
retrouvées pour débattre d'un problème
d'actualité sensible la violence
conjugale en effet la violence conjugale
est quelque chose de très délicat si
délicat qui est très probable que nous
fréquentons tous sans le savoir une
personne victime de violences
intrafamiliales
une situation que l'on cache mais que
certaines personnes vivent au quotidien
dans la crainte c'est sur cette peur que
le metteur en scène vincent fontano a
voulu attirer l'attention avec sa pièce
de théâtre tambour dans cette pièce il
ne parle pas directement de la violence
conjugale et des femmes battues mais de
cette relation parfois si étroite entre
l'amour et la peur avec sa pièce de
théâtre tambours ils souhaitent nous
amener à une réflexion plus large sur la
peur et la terreur ou plutôt comment y
résister à votre beau la tragédie donc
lundi combien précieux théâtre et se
saouler travail la question de l'amour
la question de l'homme de la femme
réunionnaise est du coup plus
réunionnais en pratique il y cinq
questions sikosana donne miam cocktail
cochrane de positif que ça n'a de
négatif même temps mais un vrai
questionnement si la peur
comme on y travaille à nos commandes et
foie de boeuf et à cri commander fois
algues et comment défendre nous quoi
devant lui commander fois une lapine
wattez a donc voilà tambour l'ailé
vraiment un espèce de de mise en
question des détenus de
l'acte d'amour voilà
ce n'est pas par hasard que vincent
fontano a choisi la relation hommes et
femmes réunionnais pour parler de la
peur et de la terreur il s'agit d'un
exemple malheureusement concret car
comme dans beaucoup de foyers à travers
le monde la réunion est aussi victime de
ce genre de violence une situation que
le conseil général combat du mieux qu'il
peut en y consacrant 5 millions d'euros
par an alors que ce n'est pas une
compétence obligatoire soutien aux
associations prise en charge
d'assistantes sociales dans les
commissariats prise en charge des
hébergements d'urgence ou de transport
via des violences mais notre propre
système aujourd'hui déconstruit le
modèle familial plutôt que d'aider à
l'épanouissement il faut aider un papa
avec la maman avec les enfants les
journaux en parlent les violences intra
familiales font partie aujourd'hui du
quotidien de la vie des réunionnais et
nous voulons aider
à ce que ces violences puissent être
prises en compte et puis nous
accompagnons la prise en charge des
enfants quand ses enfants quittent le
foyer des parents en payant aussi des
postes d'accueillant familiaux mais je
crois qu'il faut aller au delà
la violence existe il faut pouvoir aider
les conjoints à s'exprimer ne pas dire
avec les mots m à unix ceux qui
n'arrivent pas parfois à dire avec les
mots m au ts donc une prise en charge
globale du conjoint violent également
mais ça le conseil général seuls nous ne
pouvons pas le faire il faut
effectivement puisque aujourd'hui nous
avons trois députés qui propose qui a
proposé au gouvernement une loi cadre
nous attendons que cette loi-cadre donne
des vrais moyens pour la prise en charge
du conjoint violent est de la
problématique globale des violences
intrafamiliales
les violences intrafamiliales existe
depuis toujours
le conseil général est bien conscient
que c'est un sujet délicat et difficile
à appréhender la pudeur et la honte
empêche souvent les victimes de se
confier un tabou qu'il faut dépasser
pour le bien de tous de la victime ou
des enfants victimes collatérales mais
aussi du conjoint violent des
associations et des professionnels sont
à votre écoute si vous êtes une victime
n'hésitez pas à en parler le conseil
général va dans le cadre de la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes invitées des
collégiades toute l'île à une
représentation exceptionnelle de la
pièce de théâtre tambours
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais